today I'm becoming a superhero and
Amazon Prime videos new show the tick
and everyday accountant teams up with a
superhero to save the city from a super
villain so today I'm gonna learn how to
fly so fly boarding is is what it's
wakeboard boots pretty much strapped to
this fly board attached to the wave
runner the wave runner uses the power
and shoots the Lord out in the air so
it's like a water jetpack exactly by the
end of the day you're gonna be able to
cool 360 up in the air about ten fifty
feet and then dive into the water so way
I'm gonna dive down into the water and
then emerge like animalistic flying
dolphin and still be up flying and right
after that it's a super student we love
saying that you know you're a superhero
basically pretty much a superhero they
don't save anybody you know
Wow like look at just the bottom half of
this face is perfect for a superhero
mask am I crazy am I the only one seeing
this I'm gonna sidekick the [ __ ] out of
you let's do it
Dylan oh yeah count on three cuz we're
doing it okay one two three
do the Zippy thank you when you think of
me I'm more of a sidekick
but today I am going to be the damn hero
okay I admit as far as super suits go
this is my first my first fight my first
swim here we go we start super simple
it's just flying I'm a belly turn the
left and turn right then Dylan's like
you're doing great time to get up in the
air and that's what everything went
terribly I felt like a baby giraffe
trying to walk for the first time I'm
just eating eaters over and over and
over again like 10 20 feet okay two feet
sure should I've stretched before this I
would definitely recommend it great
gotta go under the nose
like all of a sudden that there's
something clicked and I am flying and I
look at the camera the camera looks at
me dailies like what up my man I'm like
what up Dale dog a video it's really
exhausting I'm sorry I've never flown
before so I've learned the basics I can
now fly and I can turn and I feel pretty
comfortable but we're not here for just
that you are you hop back in there give
it a try
why not all right let's go Thanks
oh by the way I gave you a nickname dill
dog is that cool love it great time to
try some tricks
yeah it's Theresa she's down can't get
offend your right knee
Street it again the 360 I'm doing well
with and I'm going round and around and
around look at that I can celebrate
without crashing I'm gonna try like just
diving in and out as soon as I dive I
can't see a thing and I am underneath
the water I am blind and I have jetpacks
on my feet just hurtling me towards the
unknown so I'm trying little dives just
getting comfortable and Dylan's feeling
confident me so he says let's bring it
up a little bit we go to three feet I do
the dive then five feet we're going up
and up and up it's feeling okay and then
I don't know what happens
oh I did that one to myself I'm a noob
Oh Oh I got so cocky that was the worst
wipeout I've had in my life
I just fell so hard and it's just like
the water punched me in the nuts punched
me in the face slapped me in the belly
at the same time kind of made me feel
like I have to poop
I swallowed so much ocean water I did
truly feel for a moment that this is it
I'm done I can't do this anymore so much
of my life and I think a lot of people
in this way there are just certain
things you tell yourself you can't do
like I just I can't do this I can't and
that that kind of decides it for you
right part of being a hero is not giving
up things are hard adversity is part of
the job hey you feel good I think you
should go back out there I'm not gonna
get anything done sitting here moping it
will do alive
if Arthur can do it so can I
[Music]
sticking the landing guard
to hurry
what happened I just did it and I just
loop the loop and I dive under the water
and I emerged victorious I'm Jewish so
I've never baptized but I do imagine it
was exactly like that
[Music]
they're guys
I need a nap all the time we thought you
were the hero when I was a sidekick and
it turns out you're the sidekick and I'm
the hero
oh no about that and why your greatest
student ever yeah this was just the
coolest experience of my life and what's
amazing is that like if you want to fly
you can do that we're living in a time
where super powers aren't just
hypothetical anymore but you know does
that make me a hero I don't know
[Music]
I'm coming party
I got your data
[Music]
is the first interview I've ever done
not wearing underwear I'll know cific